ce qui est vraiment bien dans les dîners
de famille c'est qu'on s'emmerde pas
c'est jamais chiant haut dans les dîners
de famille il ya toujours le doyen ultra
vieux un peu le chef
mais contrairement aux autres gens à
table lui on sait jamais s'ils s'amusent
au bas cet homme est actuellement en
train de s'éclater
moi j'aime bien les grands parents ils
sont gentils mais ils ont quand même
l'art et la manière de te faire bander
en trois secondes avec ce genre de
phrase alors ppa quoi de neuf depuis la
dernière fois où tu sais moi je mourirai
bientôt ça marche d'ailleurs c'est le
seul membre de la famille à qui on parle
de manière très très spécial d'ailleurs
moi ma grand mère elle a un délire quand
elle veut m'appeler par mon prénom
elle commence par faire le listing de
tous les prénoms masculins de la famille
s'il te plaît denis thiery jacky jean
claude stéfani daniel norman tu peux me
passer celle s'il te plait merci ma
grand mère elle adore bien me nourrir
on donne vraiment beaucoup à manger
quand j'ai faim mais aussi quand j'ai
plus fin ça normal prend du cateau à ces
gentille mamie mais j'ai plus voilà on
va prendre yaourt alors tiens écoute
momie ça peut plus rentrer dans ma
bouche la cie juge si je mange je vomis
bon ok mais prend - quality street
elle est trop gentil est trop gentille
mamie dommage quelles qu'elles soient
mortes dans les dîners de famille
souvent il ya les adultes qui mangent
entre eux et à côté il ya une petite
table dédiée aux enfants à cette table
pour enfants il ya vraiment de tout type
d'enfants de tous les âges et du coup
des fois je me demande à quoi ressemble
leur conversation coq rôti commenté dit
bon écoute ce que tu dis c'est ridicule
moi je suis en sixième c'est que tu pars
là je parle d'un mec et à fumer une
clope un coucou aux pupilles dans peau
as-tu fait dans le pot ah pardon excusez
moi j'étais mal jugé tiens prends
aguerris fais toi un cliff c'est cadeau
moi j'ai un max de thune 5 euros par
semaine je pèse ce qui est vraiment
super dans les dîners de famille c'est
que ça donne l'occasion de revoir des
membres de ta famille que t'as pas vu
depuis longtemps mais des fois ils
oublient que toi depuis tu as grandi
qu'est ce que c'est
merci tout ça mais j'ai 26 ans
maintenant les deux mignons bon allez
maintenant vas tu avais le marbre à
manger mais tata ya pas deux mais à
table les oncles et les tantes qui n'ont
pas vu depuis longtemps
il aime bien de poser dix mille
questions de manière à juger ta vie
actuelle et c'est chiant parce que des
fois on dirait vraiment que c'est la
compétition de celui qui aura le mieux
réussi sa vie
alors christian le travail ah bah moi
toujours cadre normalement je devrais
passer directeur marketing la boîte
saleh pour les actionnaires vont croiser
les doigts en attendant je reçois un
mail il toi norman ben moi je fais des
vidéos dans ma chambre pour internet
évidemment il ya un moment donné pour
arrive la question bat alors tu es une
petite copine j'ai pas moi j'arrive pas
à parler de mes relations sentimentales
avec ma famille a tancé ses intimes
je vais pas commencer à le raconter ma
vie la petite chloé là que j'ai vu en
photo c'est ta petite copine
chloé ah mais non mais chloé c'est juste
un plan cul ouais il est venu justement
s'est tenue chez noir on a indiqué comme
des gros porcs allemands ne l'était
comme ça adoré pas bon bref voilà c'est
un détail mais ça reste entre nous mais
sinon on est juste pote oui le pire dans
les dîners de famille je pense que c'est
vraiment le beau père c'est à dire le
père de sa copine faut savoir que cet
homme a une fille un sa petite princesse
a sa petite chérie depuis deux jours à
qui toi tu fais l'amour de manière ultra
sauvage et j'ai toujours peur qu'à un
moment donné du dîner ils fassent
allusion à sa à table devant tout le
monde
façon les filles au début elles sont
timides mais après une fois qu'elle
arrive au lit alors là ça y va
moi c'était clair après ça il va ce avec
un attendu par de ma fille là je parle
de ma fille ah non anna maintenant je
parlais de je parlais des autres filles
votre fille je pense pas je pense pas à
pas par manque en effet comme ça
mais comment vous parle la coop et là
c'est quoi c'est quoi ces manières 1
vous calmer hockey j'aime mieux ça fait
rigoler
c'est un bonheur
je veux donner